[Música]
muchas gracias
músico y médico
una combinación que a veces se da en
vamos a tener un poquito de aire
a gracias
les quiero contar cómo nacieron estas
dos pasiones de una manera mágica si se
quiere
y nacieron
en 24 horas
nosotros con mi familia vivíamos en san
pedro' una ciudad muy linda al lado del
río después nos mudamos para empezar la
primaria general pacheco
donde me crié y donde viví entre los
años
y en san pedro y sé que tiene infantes
en un colegio que tenía una banda
rítmica tenía varios instrumentos
triángulos diferentes elementos para
tocar
y en esa banda además había un tambor y
el tambor era lo más hermoso que había
visto
me parecía un instrumento más complejo
en vez de tener que tocar un triángulo
nada más tenía dos palillos había que
tocarlo con un control bastante especial
me fascinó ese instrumento pero los
instrumentos se iban rotando en la banda
rítmica y tenía que esperar que me
llegara el tambor no me llegaba nunca
creo que no
hasta que un día me llegó a mi mano
en ese momento le puse tanta intención
se veo tantas ganas que tenía que la
directora de la banda rítmica la
profesora de música esa primera
profesora dice bueno el tambor no rota
más lo va a tocar él
y me dijo el campo será tipo más feliz
del mundo
en los recreos del jardín de infantes
todos iban a jugar a la mancha lo que se
golpeaba la puerta de la sala de música
para entrar a tocar el tambor
yo no tenía un tambor en mi casa para
practicar si tenía a mis hermanas para
jugar a la mancha pero no tenía un
tambor donde se me parecía más
importante eso y a ella le emocionaba
eso totalmente
bueno la historia sigue de que la
familia de mis padres vivían en capital
federal a 150 km de san pedro'
obviamente en un momento hay que
trasladar a toda la familia hasta
capital federal porque había un evento
familiar y cuando mi madre le va a decir
a la gente a la profesora de música de
jardín que yo me iba a ir ese fin de
semana ella dice no por favor no sólo
lleve este fin de semana porque toca la
bandita del jardín de infantes y él es
el único que toca el tambor no no no
tengo cómo reemplazarlo
y entonces
mis padres decidieron abandonar me en
san pedro
si así como el ser vivo yo recuerdo ese
día una tarde como estas se quieren
hermosa con un sol maravilloso tocando
el tambor
allí fascinado con ese momento pero
sabía que entre la gente mi familia no
estaba y es más sabía fehacientemente
que estaba muy lejos de este lugar
entonces bueno eran las los parámetros
ideales para entrar en pánico ahí nomás
no me pasaba nada de eso me sentía la
persona más feliz del mundo me sentía
libre me sentía con todo el mundo por
delante para hacer cosas era una
felicidad increíble
bueno después de eso me quedé a dormir
en un lugar que yo no sabía cuál era era
la casa de mi padrino
no yo no conocí a mi padrino eran amigos
de la familia muy amigos pero no nos
frecuentábamos tanto y fui a dormir a la
casa de él y al otro día a la mañana
cuando me levanto descubro quién era mi
padrino
el doctor fariña era el médico de san
pedro ustedes saben la importancia que
tiene la imagen del médico del pueblo
para una comunidad es como no sé
el receptor el psicólogo cumple un
montón de funciones entonces al otro día
cuando me levanto después de desayunar
lo veo a él así
con su guardapolvo su estetoscopio
atendiendo a la gente recibiendo el
cariño de sus pacientes aconsejando las
cosas diciendo yo quedé tan impactado
con su imagen y con todo lo que lo que
me había pasado ese día que dije ya está
en mi vida quiero tocar el tambor y ser
como él y acá soy
y les
de comer cómo empezó un poco
mi vida les después de eso vinimos a
general pacheco fui al colegio número 20
donde concluido a mi primaria
y bueno tenía todos los amigos del área
remaba en este río
hemos tocado con bandas en el club
enfrente en el hispano y unos amigos
míos me han comentado hace una semana
que también tocamos a ganar regatas de
la amarilla esa primera banda se llamaba
prohibido estacionar y era una banda de
amigos del barrio
y ese fue el comienzo un poco de todo
lo que les quiero contar voy a mostrar
algunas fotos ahora
tenemos una banda muy importante porque
primero con una banda de llamada materia
gris después de las bandas del barrio y
esta banda que formamos se llama a las
tocan con gustado amor esto pero es
anarquía y tiene 17 años quizás no lo
reconozcan
teníamos que pedirle al padre que venga
a firmar los contratos de grabación o
para que pudiera viajar fuera del país
esa fue la primera banda importante
tocábamos con tres bandas uniones
hacíamos una fusión de tango que es más
o menos algo del 332 que yo tocaba
recién y eso llegó a los oídos de astor
piazzolla que vino a escucharnos
a un concierto y que elogió la banda y
nos catapultó digamos a un lugar de fama
que no habíamos tenido nunca bueno lo
increíble era terminar un concierto en
el coliseo con tres bandas uniones
sentirse una estrella de rock and roll y
al otro día levantarme temprano para ir
al hospital a trabajar sí que estaba
cursando por ahí clínica médica en ese
momento
es la formación de alas hace poquito en
eeuu con otro bandoneonista estos con
pedro aznar y néstor marconi en un
concierto en el teatro coliseo como les
comentaba antes esta es otra banda que
hicimos con héctor starc que es un
guitarrista
en aquelarre y un montón de otros lados
que ustedes conocerán y esta es la banda
con mi hija paula que yo hemos hecho
hace poquito mi hija paula es médica y
canta también tengo dos hijas médicas
julia también es médica también ha
tomado batería y ahora éste se dedica a
fotografía y otro tipo de cosas más
esas son mis clases de música en muchos
lados como comentaban recién ese es el
instituto y tmc
estos son alumnos del itd ms varios de
los que habían en ese momento nuestra
pipi piazzolla acá pero este cuando me
pidió que quería tomar clases conmigo yo
dije mira vos estás becado después de la
mano que nos dio tu abuelo a nosotros a
obtener una beca de por vida este es
otro grupo de más pequeños que
y yo coordino en venado tuerto y es un
placer trabajar con la gente de menos
edad después dentro de la formación
médica este es el hospital de mi corazón
esta es la casa cuna
acá me formé como un pediatra acá empecé
la especialidad de inmunología con un
grupo que trabajaba ahí
fui jefe del servicio de alergia y del
servicio de inmunología este es el
primer citómetro de flujo que teníamos
antes teníamos que mirar en el
microscopio y contar célula por célula
esto lo hacía automáticamente nos cambió
la vida y las posibilidades de
diagnóstico
ese es el consultorio que actualmente en
general pacheco ay atiendo pediatría y
la especialidad de inmunología y alergia
y está
en el lugar donde jugaba el fútbol tiene
una está en el mismo baldío donde ellos
juega el fútbol y remontadas barriletes
en el tiempo de formación y viajado por
varios lugares del mundo y trabajado en
españa estaba en eeuu
he vuelto a mi barrio porque yo siento
que esa imagen de médico del pueblo
sigue estando acá o sea esa persona que
tiene que estar en contacto con su
comunidad y esa es una foto de un
valiente este valiente está mostrando lo
que no le duele las vacunas yo hago una
especialidad lamentablemente que en los
pacientes que están seleccionados que
pueden recibir una inmunoterapia tienen
que recibirla a partir de los cuatro
años y son cuatro años tenemos que darle
y ósea inyecciones intradérmicas que
podemos hacer que no les duelan pero es
un tratamiento complicado no es un
entonces tenemos que potenciarlo para
que puedan superar esto tenemos un sitio
en facebook que se llama no me duelen
las vacunas y todos los genios capos que
se dan una vacuna sin llorar aparecen en
este sitio
y
contarles esto de la simultaneidad de
estas dos pasiones tiene que ver también
con un interés que pongo en el
consultorio hoy día por día cada vez que
atiende un paciente cuando ella tiene
edad de preguntarle algo trata de
potenciar cuáles son sus habilidades
les llamaría mucho la atención que ver
que muchos de los adolescentes a los
cuales le preguntó que quieren hacer no
saben qué quieren hacer entonces ha
instituido una cosa que preguntamos muy
tempranamente que quieres ser cuando
seas grande y lo anotamos en la ficha
lo que sea ingeniero lo que sea nuestra
estrategia es que eso se puede cambiar
todas las veces que uno quiera si cambio
hoy quiero ser astronauta mañana quiero
ser busto táctico lo cambiaron a ningún
problema lo que no pudo hacer es no
pensar que voy a hacer de mi vida en un
futuro y llevar a nuestros niños estas
personitas pequeñas a pensar
tempranamente en eso
es darles una ventaja si pueden
conectarse tempranamente con su paz con
sus pasiones pueden tener la chance de
poder llevarlas adelante con mucho
interés y durante mucho tiempo yo
agradezco a mis profesores que me
enseñaron a tocar música muy
tempranamente a mis padres que
verdaderamente me incentiva no para que
lo haga y trato de transmitir eso a
otras generaciones de mis pacientes
también pienso que lo básico para tratar
con una personita pequeña es el respeto
le vamos a pedir que nos respeten cuando
sean adolescentes presiones nos
empezamos a respetar nosotros como son
pequeños de dónde vamos a conseguir ese
respeto entonces una de las cosas es
escucharlos qué es lo que tienen para
decirnos y planear el tiempo que voy a
estar con ellos tratar de tener un
tiempo de calidad de comunicación
mirarnos a los ojos cuando nos hablamos
estar en contacto estar realmente en ese
momento una manera interesante de hacer
un buen contacto es cuando uno llega a
la casa no importa si tengo ganas de una
necesidad fisiológica o lo que sea lo
primero que hago es ir a buscarlos
pregunto dónde están los vuelos abrazo
les doy un beso me presento acá estoy y
ya después podemos seguir compartiendo
por ese primo
es el primer momento de mirarnos a los
ojos y de reencontrarnos o sea es
fundamental para crear una relación de
dos personas a futuro
yo no sé le pregunto quién es de ustedes
tienen al menos si tienen hijos 20
minutos con cada uno de sus hijos por
semana pueden ser juntos o en
fragmentados pero de contacto directo
personas personas sin celulares sin
reuniones familiares no cuenta el tiempo
de familia nada sino uno a uno quien es
de usted pueden juntar ese tiempo parece
muy poco pero es muchísimo entonces
tengo que planificar ese tiempo de
encontrarme ese tiempo de compartir
puedo dejar el auto más lejos
cuando lo voy a buscar a cardin infantes
oa la del colegio y en ese trayecto
demás aprovechar para hablar para estar
simplemente para compartir y enterarme
qué es lo que quieren hacer y poder
potenciar los poder tratar de generar
les más energía lo que quieren hacer en
esas personas es el futuro si no saben
que van a hacer no saben si va a ser el
futuro nuestro o sea que es muy
importante tener ese tipo de contacto
yo me tomo ese tiempo con mis pacientes
o sea me encanta la profesión que hago
me encanta tocar música tengo un montón
de alumnos a los cuales dedicó también
ese tiempo me propongo que cuando una
persona agarra el picaporte de mi
consultorio de mi sala de música para
entrar cuando se va a ser diferente
eléctrica del pasado algo tiene que
haber aprendido algo tiene que haber
cambiado algo me lo planteo como
objetivo sí y sobre todo trato de hablar
mucho tiempo con los padres y dar un
tiempo en la consulta para que aparezcan
todo ese tipo de cosas
algunos consejos que son útiles hablamos
de las inflamaciones de la vía aérea
fíjense esas inflamaciones de la vía
aérea se producen en el bronquio de un
una personita que tiene un bloqueo así
de finito entonces tenemos un problema
mucho más grave inclusive con los
aerosoles que intentó llegar no le
llegan porque la vía aérea es muy
pequeña y esa vía aérea tiene en el
bronquio digamos dentro el bronco hay
una piel de gelatina que es la mucosidad
bronquial es una barrera inmunológica no
deja pasar bacterias no deja pasar
infecciones ni sustancias irritantes si
esa gelatina no está súper fluida y
líquida no llega al aire a los pulmones
y además está voy a tener un problema de
obstrucción bronquial muy tempranamente
pero esa gelatina se seca de una manera
muy especial porque nosotros no nos
damos cuenta que cuando le prendemos una
estufa y si dejamos prendida toda la
noche a un niño le estamos secando sus
secreciones bronquiales y la consulta
más frecuente es por cierto doctor yo no
entiendo cómo este chico se enferma todo
el tiempo se está jugando calentito
adentro en su casa se división entiendo
dice
los chicos de enfrente que están en
patas con los mocos colgando esas
enfermas dijo claro esos son muy monos
en su estado natural como somos todos
somos primates y venimos preparados para
respirar este aire no un aire
calefaccionado es de decisiones seco las
secreciones bronquiales le estoy
quemando superó su primera defensa
entonces apagó las estufas de noche
desde hoy los dejó salir a jugar afuera
[Música]
y por otro lado los llevó a pasear al
aire libre todas las veces que quiera si
lo quiero enfermar loción shopping ahí
va a haber mucha gente cerrada con
calefacción y una una gran cantidad de
gérmenes entonces el problema no está en
que salgan a jugar entonces ese respeto
que tenemos que tener de tener conductas
responsables son respuestas hábiles para
este tipo de personas que dependen de
nosotros y otra cosa es a veces también
la consulta frecuente el nene no me come
bien o me come
muchas veces las madres quienes coman
verduras los pitchers y ustedes
convendrán conmigo que la comida en mal
estado tiene color verde entonces si el
pibe no quiere comer acelga no que es un
caprichoso por es tiene un instinto
natural que lo está preservando y yo
sólo voy a arruinar usted puede comer
frutas necesita comer dos vegetales por
día como buen mono que es entonces puede
comer los frutas pues comer banana
naranja lo que sea va a estar
perfectamente bien alimentado de esa
manera ese respeto para nuestros niños
esa responsabilidad como adultos que
tenemos esos verbos como personitas es
el mejor
regalo que le puedo comentar y estar
cerca de ellos para saber tempranamente
que desean y ayudarlos en sus intereses
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]